well good morning everybody and thank
you very much for your patience and
welcome to development control B today
my name is Cathy Guthrie and I'm the
chairman today and thank you everybody
for managing to get in now first of all
remind you of some domestic arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs cold water is
also available in the breakout area
outside the meeting room if the fire
alarm should stand please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs and meet on the Ipswich Town
Football Club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you are told
it is safe to do so please switch off
all mobile phones or turn them to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the Internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential exempt items if
you make a representation to the meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented to being filmed and to
the possible use of those images and
sound recordings for webcasting and all
training purposes the council members of
the public and press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded finally can members
and officers ensure that you press the
microphone for speaking and turn off
when you have finished so make the
introductions now we have in Despres our
legal officer jump general walker our
senior planner and manager Rob
Carmichael our governance support
officer Daniel who is our planning
officer today and Clare at the end we
also have committee members who will
listen to the debate and debate and come
to a decision today we have a ward
member here who also happens to be
leader of the council but she's our ward
member and she will speak as well and
ladies and gentlemen we obviously know
who you are this the supporter
being the applicants agent and the
objectives being a local resident and
you will have three minutes each except
where a dispensation is allowed for
additional things is it not
perhaps if I speak up is that any better
oh don't tempt me I normally do trying
to be quiet sorry about that well would
it be better if we asked them to move
forward if it's yeah do you want to come
forward a little bit into the next row
if it makes it a bit clearer and stop
sad echoing a bit can we help yeah well
maybe some others might be quieter as
well I'm not normally known for being
quiet can you hear me counselor you're
all right yeah exactly so you might as
well convert it just stops at echoing
right because they get the noise of the
[Applause]
so we'll move on to the agenda which is
apologies for absence and substitutions
Thank You chair none received to receive
any declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members
declarations of lobbying yes I think
we've all had no being declarations of
personal site visits confirmation of the
minutes of the meeting held on the 30th
of October with one minor amendment that
we've noted at the moment which is on
the first page is that we didn't lob
council and Norris we lobbied councillor
Norris I do beg your pardon
so that has been corrected and then I
would just ask as councillor Matheson is
going to help us in any of the rest of
it are there any further adjustments
please well at seventy three point eight
where members debated the application
etc including as design for future
applicants really as much as anything
else
I was quite keen that the that the
particular phrase about the aspect of
land and the orientation of the houses
was part of what I was saying at that
point it was it went rather beyond the
design of the proposal if members would
tolerate a little elaboration at the
point anybody else like to help me with
that no well - thanks - in between put
another phrase in talking about the
aspect of the land which way sloped and
the orientation of the houses over the
points are about design an orientation
yeah yeah good thank you members happy
with that design an orientation thank
you it's just we don't - writer life
history on there yeah we'll do that for
you yes anything else
in which case may I sign the minutes
that's the meeting thank you very much
do I get a show bangs yeah yeah thank
you very much I'll do that during the
meeting to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
councilors petition scheme none receive
chair and we have the one scheduled
application today which starts on page
19 and Daniel cameras going to present
the case cause if you'd like to do that
thank you
Thank You chair is everybody okay to
here yep okay so we previously
considered this item back in October so
I'll run through a quick update for
members we've got the original
presentation if there are any questions
pertaining to that so we can go through
those issues as well but I'll start by
running through so there are late
representations from both the objector
and the agent which are available in the
table papers and I'll run through some
of the issues raised there as well if we
go back over the reasons for previous
deferral it was for details of turning
and parking areas to be provided in in
greater detail for members it was to go
over access and parking arrangements for
disabled persons it was to look at the
detail and location of passing places to
be implemented along the access and it
was to give consideration to any
possible alternative access available to
the site so if we come here this was
submitted by the agent thank you sorry
[Music]
so it's all a bit put on to one plan but
he shows an a passing place here and a
passing place here he then chose the
boundary with the neighbor's land here
which is possibly a little bit out based
on the plans but trying to overlay
everything is probably quite difficult
now
in coming forward there's been a dispute
raised by the neighbor regarding this
area of land here so we've had an
updated blue line supplied by the agent
this indicates the land which the
applicant has ownership over if we go
back an element of that lower passing
place which is better seen here falls
outside the land on their ownership so
therefore they'd be unable to implement
it here in going back to the agent
they've indicated a solution whereby the
passing place at this point is moved
over the road onto land within their
ownership now originally when this came
before members previously we had
condition for details of passing places
to come back to us by discharge of
condition we've considered it necessary
to just we impose that at this point so
that the details applied were in their
ownership is sufficient but we'll just
make sure of that I think the previous
slide as well if we just go back also
gives a valid reason to why the
applicant isn't able to provide an
alternative access I think previously
highways had talked about an access
coming along here there's an existing
farm tract and making connection to the
road here they simply don't own this
stretch of land necessary to implement
that access so we haven't got any
alternative access arrangements for
t-today members
in terms of the previous plan we saw
there was a section highlighted I've
blown that text up there for our for our
benefit because it's a little small to
read but effectively this comes from
building control approved document b
section 5 and the adopt is the adopted
building recs document for our Fire and
Rescue Service so it talks at point six
point seven about requirement for three
point seven meter carriage by curb to
curb for operating space at the scene of
a fire to reach a fire the access route
can be reduced to two point seven five
meters over short distances in looking
into the building regulations document
no definition for short distances is
given but that pinch point is acceptable
provided the pump appliance can get to
within 45 meters of the dwelling mr. Lee
and his representation knows that this
2.75 metre pinch point requires
agreement from the Fire and Rescue
Service which would still be required
were they to go in but obviously this
requirement is not part of planning
members it's governed by Building
Control and therefore is outside of a
var arena at this particular point in
terms of mr. Lee's representation I just
wanted to bring two images that he
supplied for us in perspective here this
is an image of mr. Lee's access mr.
Lee's access is approximately 8 meters
long and is 2.8 meters wide the white
lines on either side a painted 2.8
meters apart from each other mr. Lee in
his representation proposes the erection
of fencing 2.8 meters wide so as to
restrict this element of the access and
if we go to the next image we see it
with defense panels in place now looking
at the image provided it's my opinion
that mr. Lee will likely require
planning permission given the height of
the panel's either side of the highway
the GDP Oh talks about a highway as
being something over which vehicles
normally pass and given that we have
agricultural right of access and another
rights of access over this it's likely
that
that at that height he would require a
plan for mission in and of itself for
for that in in terms of this mr. Li
contends that this 2 point 8 meter fence
line would restrict access by vehicles
probably over about 2.5 meters to get
along the access will come to the access
in more detail but effectively from this
point there's another two hundred eighty
meters for vehicles to to cross up if we
come on to some plans supplied by the
agent what they've done is I think there
was comment at the previous meeting
about redline sites and the appearance
that doors on external buildings appear
to open into the countryside they've
just left the redline site as it is but
provided closer a closer perspective of
those lines so we can see that we are
creating dwellings that just open out
into the countryside and that's also
provided some more information over the
amount of parking and the turning air is
provided for each this if we look to
bonds 1 & 2 we've then got bond 3 then
got bond 5 now the other issue that was
noted from the deferral is access for
disabled persons
so Building Regulations part and
category 1 is required for all new
dwellings
it requires reasonable provision for the
access from the point of a lighting a
car and it requires the entrances on to
provision to be located on the same
floor there are further adaptable and
accessible standards that are available
but they must be secured by planning
condition so we need to go through the
relevant tests for imposing those if we
look at the floor plans for the barns
barn one is the ground floor have an
entrance but here entrance right here an
entranceway here the to either Enda both
close to the bathroom all on one floor
and again this level access through here
and through here
if we look at bong - we've got access
points either side here and we also have
an access point here and we've got
bathroom at this point the bathroom at
this point with level access throughout
if we go to pond 3 it's much smaller
we've got an access and then the ground
floor toilet here barn 5 is the only one
that doesn't meet these tests so we have
the access and then we've got the
bathroom provided on the mezzanine above
so it would not be step-free but with
regards to requirements of Building
Regulations the underlined phrase is
reasonable provision given that we're
dealing with conversion of existing
dwellings it may not be entirely
reasonable or practical or possible to
fully comply and therefore it's left to
building regulation to decide if that is
acceptable or not but in looking at the
scope of the application and all four
bands three quarters would comply with
that requirement and I think looking
looking at band five it's simply an
issue of of the floor space being in an
adequate to provide that for them if we
go through mr. Lee's late
representations I think we've got a few
issues that he highlight so it's the
lack of access for fire tenders owing to
the restriction on the hallway or into
the restriction of the access and it's
the passing place outside the site
boundary so if we look at the passing
place issue the agent has said that
they're happy to deliver that via
condition and we'd require a condition
any point to to apply that and then we
have the issue of the access and the
restriction over mr. Lee's land with
regards to the existing rights of access
those are obviously dealt with largely
outside of planning of normally a civil
matter for resolution but in terms of
the width
we've got 2.8 meters which would be
slightly above the two points
five required by three building control
document B and if we look at the widths
of fire tenders in relation to
agricultural vehicles that at the moment
take access over the land
there are similar size in fact some
agricultural vehicles will probably be
slightly larger in order to gain access
there there is one final point I think
mr. Lee rate is I think is worth taking
a legal view on in terms of the
ownership certificate supplied with the
application in terms of that the the
time of the application the applicant
was secretary for the company that owns
this area of land and the question is
therefore whether or not the applicant
as a private individual was required to
serve notice on the company which for
all intents and purposes was the
individual thank you Daniel madam
chairman the it's very important that
the land ownership and certificate
requirements of the law are and excuse
I'm sorry if I'm if I'm losing my voice
I've got a cold OOP excuse me and the
law requires that well let's take this
in stages you don't need to own land in
order to make a planning application
however you must serve the correct
certificate must serve the correct
certificate in this case it was
certificate a which says I own the land
that you could have alternative
certificate be I don't own the land but
I've told everybody who does that I'm
making this planning application or
there's others C and D which are I don't
know who the heck owns the land I've
done my best to find out now in this
case I if I've got this correctly and
Daniel will correct me the the land
owner is a is and was a company right
there's nothing wrong therefore there is
nothing wrong with mr. Leonard isn't a
human being being the applicant because
as I've said you don't need to own the
land in order to make the application
however in an ideal world mr. Leonard
should have served notice on the company
though that would at that time was
involved serving notice on himself as
company secretary of the company is
quite right to say that a company and
the person who effectively is the
company in real life through ownership
of the shares and management is the
company thus they are separate legal
persons are something everyone learns in
their first week of a law degree however
my understanding is that the company
have communicated with the counsel I
think the letter said something on the
lines of that mr. Leonard was
effectively acting as their agent um
it's awfully nice of them to say that in
a way it is solving the wrong problem
because there was nothing wrong with him
making the application but I think III I
am interpreting that letter to say in
effect that they they regard themselves
as having been duly notified and are not
making taking a point upon this I mean I
would say madam chair you recall I've
always been very strict on this issue in
this committee you might about a year
ago we had a matter in Ricky Hall where
I think I made myself very unpopular
with applicant by advising you to
postpone something because there were
three landowners rather than one and he
was protesting they were his business
associates and knew all about it and I
said well that matters maybe but we
can't go ahead today the point is I mean
sometimes when if if somebody challenges
a permission in the High Court the High
Court has discretion and they can say
well there's no real harm done we're not
going to under and do this permission we
we unlike the High Court don't have
discretion however my advice is in all
of these circumstances that the law has
now been complied with in the light of
what the company which is the landowner
who isn't was the landowner has said but
I'll be happy to answer any questions if
any member has any more concerns about
that and I think there was one other
issue in mr. Lee's representation I
think ABARES
a little bit extra going over and that
was referenced to the hibbett test now
there is a great example of a building
that fails to hibbett test within this
site and I will just get it for you
members so you've got the images before
you but that is barn number four that is
the barn located here
now the hibbott test itself applies to
class q-bomb conversions so these are
conversions of agricultural buildings
made under permitted development but
there's not a motion to us for prior
approval and we sort of look at certain
details like highways issues flooding
issues things like that but effectively
national government presents Planning
Commission and the prior approval is
like a discharge of conditions in effect
what the hibbett test talks about is
with reference to class Q what a
qualifying agricultural building is and
in terms of class Q is the hibbett has
talked about the the structural
integrity of that building and what
works are recently necessary for
habitation or what works or not and in
effect something like this structure
here this Dutch barn open on all sides
but with a roof would fail the hibbett
test because in order to turn this into
a dwelling you defector we have to build
complete new walls here on the outside
if we look back through the application
and we look at another barn we've got
barn number three here you have walls
and a roof okay we have this large
opening here but it's probably
considered reasonably necessary to
enclose that for human habitation and so
would not fail the test
similarly with balanced - that's not a
great image I think the image of
barnable war might be more useful for
you members again we have walls and a
roof on internally within the structure
it might be relevant to insulate those
external walls it might be necessary to
take some repair works those external
walls but what the hibbott test talks
about you
is where you would be completely
constructing a external wall or wall
room that is unacceptable and the
building therefore fails to be
considered for class cube on conversion
under those those circumstances now with
regards to hibbett and the planning
history on site we previous had an
application on site made in 2018 which
considered the conversion of all five
bombs so it included barn number four
and officers decided on that occasion
that barn for did not meet with policy
it failed this this hibbett test and
that additions to barn number five went
above and beyond the scope of the policy
as well and the application was refused
we then had a subsequent reapplication
barn for was removed but the works about
five remained and we felt they were
still contrary to policy and issued a
refusal on that basis we've now got this
application before us which has been
revised substantially from those initial
applications and we now have no policy
issues with the the proposed conversions
of the of the two modern buildings they
no longer feel that that hibbott test
threshold and if I may just alleged I
think the point has been very well
explained but you have in front of you a
planning application it's perfectly all
right to grab the planning application
that means something would happen that
wouldn't be allowed under the HIPAA test
because that's what planning permissions
for play the hibbett test relates to
permitted development rights and prior
approval its relevance would be if if
there was an argument about what we call
the fallback position that well if you
refuse this application I could do it
anyway under permitted developments to
which the answer might be no you can't
because it fails the hibbett test but I
think I think that hopefully that point
is it is understood now and is fine
so if we wish through the remainder of
the the presentation so we've gone
through the reasons for for deferral
members we've gone over the parking
turning areas we've gone over the
provision for for access to a site
location plan this is unchanged we've
got the constraints overlay here for you
members we've got - great - listed barns
within the application site that's bar
number one and bar number two there's
also the greater listed farmhouse just
outside of the application site and the
sort of orange overlay represents the
fact that we've got a triple si impact
zone that's Mick field meadow
consultation with natural England with
regards to the triple si impact zone has
revealed no objection to the application
here we've got the aerial map and I
think this map is worth paying some
attention to and it shows the road
access so we have the road access within
the site within you know as patient
we've got the access here in front of
mr. Lee's property and then we've got
the remainder of the access here to the
the highway here sorry just a minute
capsule can we just finish the
presentation then we can come back to it
please we're not into questions just yet
thank you
we've got the the wider map here we can
see clearly there's a rural setting
we've got that set out in the report for
you with regards to its connectivity to
neighboring dwellings and settlement
we've got the site layout and then I'll
push through this because we've gone
through it already but we've got bar
number one and the proposed elevations
as the other side for you members 3d
site plan bar number one contains some
existing agricultural machinery which is
to be retained within this void here and
Institute terms bar number two smaller
barn again we've got a similar sort of
design palette for bar number two
reflecting the sort of more traditional
element of these two listed buildings
we've got barn number three which is
modern barn
we've got materials reflecting that so
we've got a clear differentiation
between the listed barns and this one
and then we've dropped this 3d
perspective so we've got barn number
over one two and then three in the
distance and this is for left open here
for more detail this is five and this is
the proposed
appearance here again it shows
similarities with with bar number three
in terms of the design palette here are
the photos from the access so this is
the access from from the road we've got
a neighbor and property just off here
when this is facing West and this is the
access itself this is that neighboring
property I mentioned and this is a site
access here we've got a narrow farm
track this is the track leading up to
site so here we have the aerial so we've
got the neighborhood property here we've
got the access here after they spend
that in terms of corner comes up here's
mr. Lee's property here and then this is
the access within the applicants
ownership leading up here at the end if
we have questions relating to the the
previous presentation I'll take those
from committee because I members will
remember what they remember they won't
remember what they don't remember and
I'll try and provide an update or
refresher at that point right yes
questions and councillor Matheson you
had a question and we'll get outside I
slide 19 I would just wanted to
understand what was the public highway
and what was the private road I saw that
mentioned in that in the report XO I
didn't quite get my head around how it
works in practice that was a slide that
would give us the chance yeah sorry
thank you so this is the access up to
the farmhouse this isn't private
ownership we've got the access here in
front of the neighboring property that's
in private ownership there is a public
highway at this point and there's an
element of this track here which is also
public highway and then at some point
the track refers to private ownership
yes counselor wall boys yes thank you
there have been one of the questions we
raised that the last time we looked at
this was about the access I think it's
barn two in particular which was very
tight within the red line could you just
go through the actual changes that have
happened to that to make it a better set
in iffing life for a listed building
so no thank you
so yes so their existing farm tracks
within the site coming up around it so
the access they spawn here and then
we've got access here off this farm
track the barn - so in terms of in terms
of access we'd be coming along you're
coming up into the site and then you'd
have just a reverse off the off the
track into into what effectively you're
parking now in terms of conditions we've
asked for additional details of of
actually how that's going to appear on
site how that's going to emerge to
maintained so we'd have all those
details at that point members has I
believe that's gone to on the right as a
red line around the barn that you've
been moved further away from the barn
no the red line is in the same place as
it was in the original all the the what
the agent has done is provide it
provided plans in large scale so we can
actually see that relationship better
the red line hasn't altered it remains
as it was previously I think I think
previously the red line was so far out
that when we viewed it did appear very
close but actually in in reality when we
get into that finer grain and that finer
scale we can see that we are not dealing
with things and then creating doors are
open now into the countryside
just keeping oh sorry just keeping on
that particular one are we saying that
there's only one car parking space in
the garage for that particular one it
would be one space in the garage and
then a tandem in front all right thank
you and then while I'm at it can I just
say
there's two things you said there was
machinery being kept in a bar what's
that yeah so barn one was a threshing
barn so there's some old disused antique
farm farm machinery within that that was
would have been used so you'd have this
double height ceiling for raising and
lowering things within within the barn
it's that it's that equipment that's
gonna be there's gonna be retained and
made a feature so it's not it's not
operational but it speaks to the
historic use of the barn and it's sort
of previous agricultural use okay and
then one final question sorry while I'm
on a roll the the Dutch barn can you
show the artist's impression of it shows
the barns and the Dutch barn in it yes
can you turn the lights down a bit
actually whoever it is thank you
sorry I would be right um so that Dutch
barn is outside the red line will it get
incorporated for use or what's its
intention what it's in this nice picture
yeah no we don't have any any D telling
me it could be it could be retained but
re I jumped ahead to the FERC Council
Norris you had you turned up I think
didn't you I beg your pardon
could you go back to slide eight which
was that imply a new head where you sure
the garage or the car parked in front
right thank you no to the right of the
go what is that large area there is that
a link close or is it hard standing or
so that that would be enclosed private
amenity for the use of the occupants of
that bond so that would have in effect
be their private garden one more
question
the preceding slide slide seven which
showed the true the proposed fencing you
mentioned it possibly would require
planning permission do you have any
indication of the actual height of it
yeah I think I think from the from the
restaurant ation it seems to be two
meters high I think that for the
purposes of the the general permitted
development order anything adjacent a
highway for means of enclosure can only
be a meter high if you're over a meter
you will require planning permission
right so if this was the intention of
the neighbor my advice would be to seek
applying permission before erecting okay
we can cover that one indicate when we
go forward counselor counselor Humphreys
please
no thank you I'm just questioning about
cxs who actually owns so get in my head
who actually owns that track and also
what are the current access rights to
use of that track by all properties so
let's jump back to this one because it's
a bit closer so this section of the the
track is within the ownership of the
applicant there's a section of track
here which is in highways ownership
there was a section of this track here
that's owned by a third party there is a
section of track here that is owned by
mr. Lee so at the moment this site is
farmed actively and there is right of
access presumably for the residential
use of the farmhouse
at the end of the track also residential
might have access for mr. Lee's property
here and probably for agricultural
vehicles to access the land as well
thank you I'm sure lots of probably's in
there so on the legal side of life how
does the access rights for that farm
that it currently is in place go forward
to any development obviously as we've
said often in this room the land
ownership and Planning Commission are
two separate things on the other hand
the practicalities arising from land
ownership may be a material
consideration to whether you have to
think about when you decide whether or
not it's right to grant permission
councillor Mori if it's a question if
not can you save it - thank you chair -
the picture of mr. Lee's driveway the
pictures of mr. Lee supplied with is in
the next one so am I right in thinking
that there is mr. Lee's private it
that's not that is not public highway is
it and it's not in the ownership of the
applicant so we can get confirmation of
that from the applicant so it's my
understanding from mr. Lee the he owns
this stretch of road I don't think this
stretch of road is public highway I
think it's privately owned but I think
that the provisions of the the GDP oh
don't make don't make a differentiation
between what is public highway and was
private Highway it just talks about
highway and I think that for the
purposes of potentially being planning
permission I think that would that that
would that would bite at that point
because I think that the the GDP would
recognize that where you had you know
privately maintained Road you would
still want for
vehicular safety the same sort of
visibility splays that you might on a on
a publicly adopted road can I just ask
the the fencing and you say he would
need planning permission for if it was a
meter but and one right in thinking it
doesn't really matter whether it's one
meter or two meters you still won't get
the fire engine around that corner would
you because that is the minimum width
and a fire engine you think it's going
straight yes but going around that bend
you wouldn't get for me today fire
engine if that was even if it was only
so the the the 1 meter 2 meter
differentiation is purely whether or not
mr. Li might need planning permission
for what he wants in terms of of gaining
access we have the comments of the Fire
and Rescue Service they've been provided
with details of the of the updated
scheme and we have their comments before
members in the bundle now I take the
point I think it might be difficult to
to have visibility beyond if the height
of that fence is 2 meters I think it
might be difficult to then also maneuver
it's not it's not a tight Bend if we go
back to the blue line there is a bend
but then that is you know we could grant
the planning permission at this point if
the applicant wasn't able to implement
the access that would be something that
their own risk if we came to signing off
for for for building control to say that
it was an approved access and they
couldn't demonstrate that that again
would be be at their own risk there
might be things that they can be showing
here that they then cannot implement
in reality and and that is part of the
risk of of undertaking development that
they might then not be able to implement
the permission I was granted and would
need to seek to either redress that I'll
come back with a fresh application any
further questions for the officer not
rather debate but further question caso
Carter just regards the access as well
could I just confirm the distance
between where the car parks and where VA
access is via the main access points
also I did want to wonder regards the
machinery that's going to be turned into
a feature who is going to maintain
maintenance or that machinery does that
impact on the does that make any impact
on the floor the passage to to entrance
points is that like is it possible for
that sir to cause any hazards in the
future so into in terms of the the
access within a proof document RM there
are requirements for level access from a
lighting a vehicle at its closest point
to the entrance point and that's all
detailed within the building works
documents as approved with regard to the
machinery this is sort of this is
non-functional is is in there at the
moment but has not been used for a long
time and wouldn't restrict it's not
located in a place that would restrict
someone from being able to access the
property or from being able to deal with
it and I think with regards to ongoing
maintenance that would be a case of
whoever then subject to the works being
completed whoever then chose to purchase
that property and live there the ongoing
maintenance would be will be for them it
would be the same
you know we we as individuals buy a
house and we notice that there's a
chimney that we may have find out is
tilting or something like that it would
be the private individual responsible
for the maintenance Thank You councillor
Matheson thank you just going back to
the previous answer from the officer
they're all about the implementation as
opposed to the permission are you saying
that the the implementation would have
to satisfy both building regs and the
fire service yeah so approved document b
talked about a number of things that we
need to be satisfied in terms of
building regulations so we'd need to be
content that whoever was certifying the
building was content with it that B
could be our own building regulation
service that could be an approved
inspector volunteer regulation with
regards to provisions of document B
those are normally also run past the the
fire and rescue service as well
given that it does relate solely to
issues of accessibility and fire and
things like that right thank you very
much indeed we don't have anyone from
the parish council but we do have mr.
Barry Lee the objector and you may have
four minutes for the medical reasons
thank you
before more minutes
I'm sorry you don't start anything else
you start your four minutes and that's
it thank you the planning committee
cannot make any decision based on
information that's wrong the information
supplied by planning officer just now
about the access route is completely
incorrect so we can't make a decision
that's it well on what grounds are they
incorrect you need to explain it please
and this will be your this will be your
four minutes show me the plan of the
whole access road I'm going to lose all
my information but mr. Lee we've read a
copious amount but yes absolutely
the the description of the access road
is completely incorrect if you give
incorrect information and then you make
a decision on it then the decision is
void that's it do you want me to explain
do you want me to explain the access
road if mr. Lee is saying that he cos
agrees with the information then it's
his opportunity to correct it and to say
why he thinks it's wrong that's not the
case I came to put forward my case but
the new information he's it blows me out
of the water because it's completely
incorrect the the committee can't make a
decision based on information that is
incorrect
it's incorrect it's not just a little
bit incorrect it's completely incorrect
if it were the case that that the
council the decision maker the plural
here the councillors were misled or
misunderstood an important fact that
that is potentially a ground for legal
challenge but we I think what we're I'm
saying what the Chairman is saying mr.
Lee is that you please tell us where you
think we that there's error well okay
well then we'll start again please madam
chairman with that withering set Road on
the left the first l-shaped
track all the way to the field house is
public highway all the way not some of
it or vaguely become and you just stop
there can you just do that with the
counter so that the members can see
which particular bit worked on there
that all the way along there to their
2.7 meters wide in places to the field
house past the field house to a piece of
track that is 8 meters long you said it
belong to the field house it doesn't
then there's a track goes to the farm
that doesn't belong to the applicant it
belongs to Balamory Capital Partners
that's 2.7 meters
the track is 2.8 meters so you've not
said anything about the fact that the a
meter track belongs to someone else
completely different well can I help it
may we stop again please
I I repeat this is important that the
decision-makers have the correct facts
however I'm just looking and stating the
obvious I mean that that what mr. Lee's
describing is outside the blue line of
home stood correctly I mean it's
important that the committee understand
all relevant facts that go to their have
relevance to their decision I'm not
quite sorry if I'm being dense I'm not
quite getting the point mr. Lee
ownerships and he's not saying that that
the highway goes all the way out to the
eight meter section he's not saying that
the eight meter section belongs to
someone else you're saying it belongs to
me it doesn't
so it's wrong the the presentation is
incorrect would you like to tell us
which bit if we put the picture up where
you've got the potential fencing would
you like to point out to us which bit
you and that would be very helpful
would that knot right there there's a
new thing that says end of public
highway that's fairly obvious to me the
bit in front of it isn't vaguely belong
to someone that's the end of the public
highway that's why I've put my posts at
the end of the public highway the track
beyond there belongs to another
landowner and we've got rights over that
track the track is 2.8 meters wide
okay make the fences a meter high or
whatever avoids cleaning applications
but you won't get a fire tender through
there ever hang on a minute we're just
trying to decide and get the clarity on
the the ownership of the land so for us
all where the blue line says end of
public highway everywhere aside belongs
to the public highway so work work
content with that and the little posts
on the left shall we say one two three
four up to the blue line is that the
public highway or on your a bit of land
be me and to me no way right knocked
away rights over it yeah so from the
blue arrow round the corner to where the
long red one drops in yeah
you're saying that belongs to someone
else unknown at the moment yeah are not
allowed I don't know if I'm allowed to
say it long stupid well it would be
helpful so cool it let's call it choice
it's it's mr. chase who owns all the
loan okay grab suits so there's that bit
of land where your proposed fencing for
how many meters there it can be 1 meter
it can be half a meter but it's still
prevents alright but it's somebody
else's and then beyond that is the blue
line which is what we're looking at
which is what we can make a planning
application decision on what happens
outside becomes a civil matter but I am
correct and I'm not yes but we need the
clarity which you're kindly giving us
and that's helpful so members are you
happy with what we've tried to tease out
at the moment counselor good thanks I'm
I'm I'm a little confused in terms of I
understand well the point about
considering all relevant matters that we
need to have accurate information I'm
struggling with the materiality of what
what miss Lee is saying or a less polite
way I suppose is so what what difference
does that make
in terms of the decision that we need to
take as a committee if I wasn't here you
would make a decision based on
information is incorrect and that's not
allowed
well I think it's not quite I don't
think it's quite as simple as that
because it is about materiality of that
of that in place a so that's exactly
right counseling and can I just asked
legal and we'll ask it in the open forum
is that if mr. Lee is unhappy with any
part of the process he has the right for
legal objection a judicial review
depending on whatever the decision is of
the committee we are looking at the blue
line and we can make a decision one way
or the other on what we have before us
within that blue line and quite right
madam chair thank you so if we may
continue then if you'd like to continue
and you will have yours we're still
holding and you've got sorry for my
strong on the first plan the new plan
that was supplied it we've talked about
the two point seven meter 2.75 meter
access that the fire brigade require
over a short distance the next sentence
is provided the pump can get within 45
million meters of the dwelling entrance
to any entrance 280 meters away so that
that's gone that's the very next
sentence that two point seven five
meters doesn't exist I've got to skip
through some other things in order to
get to the important bits if we were
minded to increase the width on our onto
our land the fire brigade actually want
three point seven meters over the whole
of that track
that's the prop the public highway our
air room eight meters belong to chase
and the 280 meters down to the farm the
five guide want that to be three point
seven meters I'm asking how would the
Planning Department or the council
ensure that the rest of the 738 major
axis is also three point seven meters
wide curb to curb because that's what
the fire brigade require I've spoken to
five grade on this and it's they will
want the whole track to be three point
seven meters wide
how are the planning committee that the
council going to ensure that weapons
I don't agree with the heebie suggestion
because planning application to was
refused because the barn
forget barn five-on-three has never been
hadn't changed at all yet that failed
the hibbett threshold last time it
should fail the heebie threshold this
time on three you said it's got walls it
hasn't got walls it's just got cladding
on it it's got post foundations he's got
a dirt floor the whole bond would
disappear he's not a conversion of
agricultural building is a new build as
a new build
there's a statement 4.6 that say that
lumps everything together all four bonds
so that 4.6 is incorrect the the
application for the ancient bonds has
got to be separate to the application
for the bonds that are modern they don't
pass the hibbett threshold they're
modern and new builds in which case all
the sustainability issues that section
4.6 tries to extinguish or avoid the
sustainability issues you must come in
so the three modern bonds must be a
separate application barn fire for
instance has never had a structural
survey it's only bolted down on a couple
of bolts on each leg it's got a
mezzanine floor
you can't put a mezzanine floor in a in
a casual geek you hippie it just fails
it fails well I mean really the
information that's come today we will
ask some questions which might help you
there and well it depends what the
committee want to do I can't direct them
what to do but we will have some
questions did you want to just just
respond to a couple of things there
please
queries so we are looking at a planning
application this is not a classic your
application the therefore barns in
question and I think what we're saying
is there a is a potential that the agent
could argue there is a fallback position
for klasky for those now the respondent
before the whole barn was excluded from
the application because we are content
there is not a fallback position that it
would not be conversion under hibbett it
would be what is classed as fresh built
now because we're not looking at a
classical application it is merely that
could be a fallback position and we've
got to consider they do not they haven't
sort of klasky but the reasonable
likelihood
that they couldn't would is something we
need to consider and I think what we're
suggesting is that there is a reasonable
likelihood that they would be able to
convert those underclass q should they
seek to do so I said they have not
actually got that classic in place but
we have to bear in mind that that could
be a fallback position in due course for
development of this site so that's where
we sit with this there is no issue with
a planning applications regard needing
to separate the different barns out we
have planning policies that support
banker versions whether that is listed
not listed or anything in between if you
will so we are looking at this as a
conversion of full barns under a local
plan policy
so hopefully that provides a bit more
clarity on the klasky situation and
that's Jeff thank you very much that's
help from that can still hunt for uses
or questions for you now sure thank you
I'm just two questions really first one
is have you put in planning permission
for fencing as of yet I don't need to
apply because I could reduce the fencing
to your situation it doesn't need
permission but it's still restricts
taxes that's great and that's debatable
because it's only one meter I don't need
to bring in my wing mirrors but we'll go
into that and debate in a minute whether
we can get through or not and just to
point correction really you said the
fire brigade need three point seven me
actually it's clear and it's been it's
been evidence today that they'd accept
two-point 70s or a short distance and
that's that's that's the fact is it not
so that is what they would accept if it
comes back to them and they find that
acceptable I think the point that mr.
Lee is making is that the 2.75 the next
sentence within the adopted document B
says that they will accept that travel
through the pinch point provided they
can then get to within 45 meters of a
dwelling
that's that 45 meters of a dwelling is
standard for all fire tenders for
buildings where it is I think what mr.
Lee's point is that in constructing the
fencing it would frustrate the access of
their fire tender
to within 45 minutes so they would be
unable to move beyond the point of the
fencing and there would still be 280
meters from the dwellings themselves is
that yeah so slightly confused so it's
not question but it's trying to answer
this question so it's they'll get clear
in my mind
the fire service will accept two point
seven five meters over a short distance
to use your pinch point fact which will
then as long as it allows them to get
moving 45 minutes of dwelling before
surely once they through the pinch point
two point seven five meters they've got
two hundred and seventy two meters to
get to the dwelling so therefore it does
pass that test yeah no that's that's my
interpretation as well I was just trying
to would you mind
so I think where we're coming to us also
is is that we're all clear that the two
meters would be listen to a cappella
Commission given where we were found
with the highway as a meter as you
mentioned you haven't let's fold in here
when we're is it's got less constraints
so if mr. Lee were to choose to do that
it wouldn't have the same impact there's
a two meter high which would require
planning permission so there is a slight
separation between the two points
and just a point of clarification on
something you mentioned for the section
of the road that's public highway
between the main road and your property
do you know how what the width of that
section of the road is about the whole
section of the road measured accurately
using GPS satellite systems and I know
exactly every point along the road its
minimum is 2.5 meters that's over a
meter less than Phi Brigade require the
average is 2.7 meters throughout the 450
meter length at the whole road is too
narrow for the Fire Brigades
requirements and I have a question with
regard to that what would happen if
there was a fire at the current
farmhouse then as I said we might be
minded to allow onto our land so that
the three point seven meters could be
accommodated no no my question is what
would happen to the dwelling that's
already there if the fire brigade needed
to get through would your restrictions
stop that or and or what happens now it
can get through it get through now yeah
easier to get out than unlocking the
fence that's there the gate that's there
at the moment that's locked we have to
look at what's there now not what might
be there so that's a point would that be
correct
and then there's another question I have
farm machinery my goodness me it gets
bigger and bigger and bigger so you'd be
restricting the access to farm machinery
should the farm continue to farm is that
correct yes or no the farm machinery
doesn't go through that gate it goes the
other side of the pond at the moment the
gate through and the place where the
policy place was in the wrong place
there is an access for chase but it's
only an insurance policy for the future
thank you yes counselor good sorry I
jumped in so it's actually a question
for for the for the lawyer is that
permitting listen which it which is
really the the imposition it kind of
follows on from your question Castle
Guthrie the imposition of metal posts
and fence does that offend the rights of
those who have current rights over
access along that road if you is that
question clear it might be depending on
the precise circumstances of what those
rights are and exactly what's done I
mean it's difficult to be very more
specific with specific than that I'm
afraid
yeah the short answer is yes it might I
think we've got to be careful we're
talking a lot about outside the redline
and we need to sort of and I appreciate
it I'm doing it as well but we need to
vamp clarity for the applicant so thank
you has everybody had the questioning
sufficiently thank you
if you'd like to return to your seat
please thank you very much indeed yes
well I think we've had sufficient time
no thank you so we - mr. James Tanner if
you would for the applicant thank you
okay good morning madam chairman fellow
councillors first apologize might slight
tardiness this morning and delaying
proceedings
I'm James Tanner from Collins architects
and surveyors and I'm the agent acting
on behalf of the applicant I'd like to
thank the planning officer for a clear
description of the proposal
and confirmed that since the last
committee meeting we have sought to
address some of the design and layout
issues raised by councillors and I think
the introduction of vehicle passing
places and some apparently on the
parking layer around that the pros
dwellings we've been able to do this
these revisions have been deemed
acceptable by the planning officer and
again I would just like to clarify that
the passing place has suggested our on
land which is in undisputable control of
the applicant as well as the proposed
versions the original farmhouse
Greenwood farm house is located adjacent
to the north and northern edge of the
application site which along with the
barns has been served by the current
access road for far longer than the
principle objectors house has been in
existence the current access provides an
approach for all the farm traffic that
used to serve greenwood farm and indeed
the previous owner has retained some of
the surrounding farmland which is also
served by a right-of-way over this
access for all types of modern
agricultural vehicles
therefore both owners must be allowed
access that sufficient is wide enough
for all farm vehicles along with for
example domestic refuse vehicles which
are an effective trim to the size of
fire engines I think it's worth
highlighting here that and as a point is
pre mentioned earlier that if it were to
be a fire for say at Greenwood farm
house and access has been intentionally
restricted by the neighbor by the
installation of fences and posts as
shown in the latest objection this could
result in very serious consequences for
the farmhouse occupants Kansas have
clearly had the opportunity to weigh up
the planning policy considerations and
yet of the application at a previous
meeting and I don't want to go through
all those again but I would like to
confirm in terms of the building program
and sustainability may
we'll be put forward to ensure that the
conversion of the barns is completed to
a close to as pacifies stands as as
possible with things like charge points
are clearly believed Wellings I think in
conclusion really I think whether or not
the current occupier field house tries
to put up a fence to thwart the legal
right of two landowners to use the
access drive for agricultural and
domestic vehicles is not in our opinion
a material planning consideration it may
result in the need to seek legal
clarification in the future but it is
not a reason to withhold or not a valid
which to a hold grant of planning
permission in our opinion in this
instance and therefore I respect request
councillors to approve the application
thank you thank you very much do members
have questions at all no yeah I guess
cancelable boys it's please do you've
just affirmed that the applicant has got
control over the amount of land needed
to provide the passing points after
field field house I'm sorry after field
house yeah I was proposed to be passing
points on the access track its agreement
farm yes and you've just affirmed that
the applicant has control over the land
where he can put those access point the
passing points yes I see
yes indeed counselor yes yep for the
passing point as in that you know to the
delay by shape pulling is to allow a
traffic but that's past that the field
has and into the last in the ownership
of the applicant so the passing points
put in all privately owned track are
those which are in land controlled by
the applicant so that's away from the
controversial pinch point part with that
with any further questions no thank you
very much could you turn the button off
please thank you very much if you'd like
to return to you
and we now have counselor Susie Morley
who will speak on behalf of the
community at large
thank you - as I've mentioned before I I
live in a converted barn and so my
natural inclination is always in favor
of this type of development but my my
concerns on this are not so much with
the development itself but with the
access and I know that you're very clear
that it's outside the blue line but the
field house doesn't even get a refuse
collection to it because the track is
not fit for our own mid Suffolk refuse
lorries to go down and instead the the
bins have to be walked 450 metres right
all the way down to weathering scent
road now if our refuse lorries can't get
to the field house then they're not
going to get to this new development
either
the at the moment the residents of the
fieldhouse can observe traffic coming
and going and they can you know take
steps to avoid agricultural vehicles
coming through but the I still cannot
see how large vehicles like our refuse
lorries like our fire engines even
dilute delivery lorries the Tesco's man
how they will be able to get to this
site and one I think the design of the
two old farms brilliant they're really
nice
nicely designed there is also talk that
on the new ones it refers to demolishing
the missing Nissen Hut and rebuilding it
so that is not a conversion that is a
rebuild there is a total new build a
very little structure of those three
barns will be retained so I do I still
do not see how if this application is
approved it can ever be delivered
because the axis cannot be cannot be
guaranteed
only I'll leave it there thank you a
moment cancer yeah I think that picks up
on the kind of the klasky versus
planning application query that yes
although they are essentially rebuilding
the Nissen hurts that's something for
members to consider why do you think
that is acceptable if we were
considering underclass q you get into
substantial rebuild you get into fresh
build that then does caused you problems
with Hibbert's but because we're looking
at a planning application not a class q
that would be for members to decide
whether they think that would be
unacceptable or embrittle anywhere
policies rather than a problem in itself
and counselor i have a question and you
advised about the refuse from mr. lee's
harris what happens to the refuse from
the farmhouse do you know i don't know i
assume that they have to do this all
right okay thank you yeah so so the the
the if accepting mr. lee's submission
that the the public highway reaches his
property so so you're saying that the
our refuse vehicles can't traverse the
public highway to his property are you
yes that's true because they they would
have to reverse up and they can't
reverse that distance along that round
that right angle Bend so because if they
go up there then they can't get back out
again other than reversing all the way
blindly onto the main our we can't slack
on frozen i'm sure thank you and it's a
question really sort of partly you've
almost answered it is it not correct
that the reason they won't drive up
today is there are no turning points but
the truth is that if this plan goes
ahead and
and the passing points and the larger
area at the end of the field there would
be adequate senate points it won't
benefit everybody with the refuse
collection is it not also true that in
rural areas such as this it is common to
tape your bin down the track two or
three hundred meters and leave it by the
side of the road because the problem is
if people don't in rural communities and
part of the reason it's acting its
requested is that it would delay refuge
collections across the county so
therefore if every track would never
guess the question yes so is it not true
that it's not just because of the size
of the track or over factors that
actually determine whether that rubbish
is collected from field house they'll
feel farm or from the actual roadside
yes and in fact my my babies have to be
walking to the end of the track yes it's
quite normal
any further questions for councillor no
thank you very much well we're open for
debate now that's been quite a lively
start to the proceedings so who would
like to kick off for them please
councillor Humphreys always get it so
I'm just so you can jump in I'll start
super can I think it's it's been covered
really we're looking at the site of the
planning the planning application itself
it's the red line issues the access is
definitely poor lot comes out at the
moment it in a moment but really it's
about the the actual site itself and
when you look through this and you look
at the changes the compromises been made
throughout this process the actual plan
for the construction site is really good
and it's an excellent use of old
derelict buildings that if they're not
used for something will be derelict and
will fall down and go up miss got views
so it seems to me the logical things
turn to housing the quality of the
design from what I can see on the paper
is top-notch I always look at things as
would I like to live there well yes it
would definitely it's it's a great place
to live and I think the buildings are
fine
I think the accessibility and everything
else has all been thought of as well
enough turning points the whole thing Oh
nothing wrong with the plan whatsoever
and I can't find any planning reason to
turn this down on that plan when we come
to the access we discussed the access
part that is highways part of it is
under the ownership of the applicant and
and there's an 800-meter as sorry as an
8 8 meter strip where we've got a little
bit contention and my consumer this is
and I'm sorry mr. Lee I do I honestly do
feel for you but to put up a fence to me
is wrong and it's wrong for a number of
reasons it's wrong because the current
applicant the current resident in the
farm is then put at risk
well that's unacceptable I think in my
world totally unacceptable because
you're saying that if you put the fence
at four engines won't be able to get
through so therefore if you put that
fence up you're actually denying him a
right of rescue and there's no debate on
this this my point and I think that's
unacceptable I also think it's
unacceptable that that would actually
compromise the new residence of this of
this this application and it's wrong
however I do get your point about plant
permission to go for a one meter fence
now and you know what if I was in the
fire engine I don't know this for a fact
and they need to get to a point of
rescue they will ignore your want me to
fence and drive through it so it's
pointless and honestly it's just making
it difficult for everybody and wasting
your money in your time there is enough
room for a fire engine to get through
it's not articulated to get through that
gap it's a short pinch point it's
accepted by the fire service that they
can accept 2.75 meters of which they've
got fact they've got point naught naught
5 extra so that's the issue with this at
all
and of course planning permission even
if we grant it today that if that's the
case that's where it goes it will be
subject to that access right so if they
can't get access eventually it isn't
going to happen
so it's irrelevant really because that's
not our it's not our decision it's
nothing to do with us we're concerned
with the construction site well one
thing on the access though in insula in
your side is that of course then you've
got larger trucks how do they access the
construction site but again that is
outside of it
planning committee because go getting
that sis you're not gonna get the
planned permission even if we even if we
pass it today so I don't see that the
access this we've all gone down this
brief I don't see the access is a
massive issue for us today when we're
determining whether to permit or
otherwise this actually planning
application which on paper seems quite
sound there my points
I hope it's balanced huija no actually
it's me and just a point of order well
not a point of order a point of
information is that the person who owns
the 8 meter stretch of land hasn't
objected so I just thought I'd to throw
that one into the mix for members to
consider so was it John were you next up
yes thank you thank you I mean I I agree
with a great deal of that I think the
the in you know in common sense terms
the public would look at this and say
well yes it's not it's not quality
development because it's it's got these
problems with it but as we've winkled
out over over the hour the the planning
issues on which it will might be refused
are very narrow but what I had what I
was just searching for and I have just
just found it now it's on page 51 it's
actually the detail of the highways
submission a which is actually
reproduced on page 22 are just trying to
see whether there was more detailing
there isn't really and that is that
there's an ambiguity that they're saying
that that there is a need for passing
places and the the they haven't actually
said whether they're talking about the
public highway section of the access or
they're talking about the the the the
the the applicants ownership land as to
where these might be needed and and I
you know I think that that that may well
be and again that a condition will
require that
be sorted out but I just I just do look
at that that very particular point quite
what yeah and so obviously they could
only do work to leave the appellants own
land so that would be what highways
would normally be looking to seek if
they were looking to do works on
highways land to enable this they would
be seeking a section two seven eight
agreement and there's no reference to
that for the public highway aspect of
this and as we've seen we've now got
passing places proposed within land
stated to be within the applicants
control yeah I mean I think what's why I
was looking for their detailed letter
that the you know I think the ambiguity
remains because they probably haven't
recognized where the public and private
sections are yeah I mean they would have
the red and blue red line for the
applications so I can be aware that
that's that and and they will know what
is public highway and as in normally
they would say to us it needs passing
places will do this by section two seven
eight agreement because this is highways
land this case they've asked us for an
amendment that's on the application site
yeah we've done that anyone else
counselor Google to think thanks sir I'm
chair as so often now I'm very grateful
to councillor Humphries was very clear
exposition of the position I think and
distinguishing the the proposals for the
conversions themselves and then the
development from issues of of access I I
to find the development very attractive
I find the idea the the opportunity to
preserve those buildings in the way
proposed a very positive a very positive
thing issues about access of what we
spent most of our time talking about and
there's a limit to which
those as has been said have a bearing on
the the planning decision before us I
had to like answer Humphreys a somewhat
unsettled by measures that may be put in
which increase the risk to the residents
at the farmhouse
and to to this development but I see
nothing in and and taking what he's
written particularly in respect to the
fire service and see what they have
written in terms of their requirements
has been supposed to being told by mr.
Lee what they've told him the
requirements well he's quite right in
terms of the need for us to satisfy
ourselves about the information that we
are using in terms of base our judgment
and I'd rather go on what I see in
writing from the service itself in that
in that regard so I mean if there are
issues of access then that may will
cause difficulty in terms of the
realization of this application but
other than that I find it a very very
attractive application thank you
well I will repeat about the thought
that's gone into the design and the
preservation of the modern and the
ancient curtilage surrounding the
farmhouse we've got two - listed
buildings which we preserve but you're
also preserving that kind of historical
contemporary context
I question for me is it is about the
sustainability of the site I had a quick
count of the the bedrooms it's 23 people
possible I can be corrected but I think
it's twenty three bedrooms anyway our
bed spaces for buildings is going to be
possibly a vehicle to choose a
substantial amount of extra traffic they
enough put down what has been
established has a very narrow track so
so my question is really in my mind
about the sustainability
site and an isolated rural relocation
without any suppose I can tell public
transport thank you for that who else
would like to speak sorry did I hear did
I see yeah anybody else like to speak no
um well well I sort of move this along a
little bit like my colleague I counsel
Humphreys I have every sympathy with the
problems that are surrounding mr. Lee I
to live on a single tract lane and I too
have had development next to me over ten
years
in fact and I too have four families I
think now but we manage they pass in my
gateway they pass in my driveway
as regards the refuse collections my
neighbors used to have them on the top
of the roof and they'd come up the lane
with them dropping off regularly and
they'd have to get the kids out to pick
them up and we put them at the end of
the lane but mid soffit came up trumped
and they have a small collection vehicle
which actually can now get down and turn
round at the bottom and so I have that
opportunity I went from a very quiet
rural living if you like to somewhat
more active and with four children three
ladies who are going to have their
boyfriends and so on and everything
traveling I know what your concerns
might be but we rub along together we
get on very well together they've
enjoyed their rural life and I've
enjoyed my rural life and I'm still
living there happily and I think
regarding I'm not going to go on about
the access because that's something
we've had many applications where we
give permission and everything else
outside gets caught up in either
building regs or everything else and
that's not our decision here today there
are routes that you could go down if
members are minded to approve it and
that is your right but I think
looking at everything that we've got by
way of design if there were only two
barns being developed that would
otherwise fall into disrepute we're in
the same problem of problems of more
traffic building and so on the
construction traffic I'm not giving out
my life history here but I've had a
place where we've actually had to have
smaller construction traffic coming in
so you can insist on it so it can be
arranged and it should be for the peace
and quiet of the neighbors and the
neighborhood so I'm in favor of this but
I am NOT happy that we have a very
unhappy neighbor and I would hope that
things can be alleviated shall we say so
I would be in favor of this application
so I want people to move on we've had a
long time does anybody councillor
Richardson please Thank You Sharon I
think I will touch briefly upon two
points one I think is just to reiterate
many of the points that have already
been made about the design about the
layout I think there's I was gonna say
there's nothing objectionable and no
grounds for refusal on that basis but
actually I would go further and say that
I very much welcome and to design very
much welcome this style of development
where it does improve not only I think
does it deliver high-quality houses but
also preserves what are significant
heritage assets and I've seen that in
what across my ward and it's been done
very well and it's produced really
high-quality housing and in good and
appropriate places I think there are
still concerns about access I think
we've talked about them to a great
extent I think it's not an ideal
situation but I think as has already
been said of the fire service need to
get somewhere they will I mean the
reason I asked about the section public
highway I was interested to find that it
was a at a minimum 2.5 metres well then
if they've got issues at the moment
getting to the field house and the
farmhouse then I don't see why under
those circumstances we could then say
well you see they now that we've got an
additional four homes it's gonna be
impossible for them to do so and so
whilst I recognize those reservations
around axe
I do think they can be properly managed
to mitigated through building
regulations and conditions and so the
interests of moving this on I would like
to propose that we accept the offices
recommendation and approve this
application Thank You councillor who
else would like to speak counselor
Matheson yeah as I said this isn't
quality development given given the
difficulties that it has but but you
really we wouldn't realistically
refuse it on the basis that it what
didn't meet mpps general observation
that italy you know we should approve of
equality it is a very unsustainable
location the the conversion of the
modern buildings really without class
hue behind behind this as as gemma has
effectively described it now you know I
wouldn't be voting for approval but as
it is there are not reasons to refuse so
are we second the young approval Thank
You councillor Matheson does anyone else
wish to speak or can we go to a vote on
what we've heard no shall we go to the
vote then I have a proposer and a
seconder are there any further have we
checked the conditions I would like to
just check sometime oh I think there's
something in here there's something
about bats but I wonder whether we can
put some our boxes off I don't know
whether it's specified in there I know
no but I don't know whether the proposal
and second Dunedin
I think so I think all the conditions
are on page 36 of the report members in
terms of the ecological mitigation
there's some enhancement measures and
yeah we can definitely make sure that
includes our boxes bird boxes bat boxes
those are sort of things you find in yep
right okay I'm anxious the yeah the one
that I picked up in the in ecology
report they were saying if if the
demolition was described I suppose there
is some if the works that say were in
the winter then that they it was
recommended that there would be on-site
ecologist because of the the night unit
of the great festive news and possibly
run into others yes it's actually in the
recommendations there counselor ecology
report to be implemented yeah so have
everything that they include in their
ecology report that they're gonna do
we're conditioning to say you will do it
as you set out so on that basis then we
have a proposal in a second or all those
in favor please vote all those in favor
of the recommendation
and those against one thank you very
much indeed
thank you are there any site visits
recommended no Jeff no site visit so in
that case then we now close the meeting
thank you very much everybody
thank you
[Applause]